GRHE0 PRESIDENTIAL
JURY THAS TON 2020 TG OFAVDAY BA
ELECTIA FEDERATO
LINDSEGR NOT GOING H SUBPOEN
GRULD DE
PAUSE ON THIS BECAUSE I'M APALE
AONN FIRE LIKELTO SUCHE THEY AT
COURT
P AES
REQUIR TUESDAY APPEAWHPPAYS RE
DIRIS
THATRACIALTNESS.A,
THEY ARE PARLAIN AALM HAWITHF S
BRADFEENSPERGECA AWAIKE SENATE
BALLOTS.SET GRAND JURYN  CNNGTS
THISOW
I WANT TO BRING  M
ZELDINSTF "THAT H
MIPOGOOD TO SESTILL
GHCOUR
AN GEO.
YOU CONVD
IFN  H.
IOUT IS THE  AND DEBAT OF THE N
ATIVE WORK ARE SOMETHING
RYABOUT, YOU CAN BE PREVHAE.
T
AND OTHER CALLS THAT H
TOPLE IGISLATIVTHE COURT SAID,O
LEGISLATION AND,, YOU HAVE TO A.
NEW JERRIED TO DO THE SAMIN HEY
IN CNEWITH HOBIN
ACTIVITIES.T SAID NO, NO, NO,'S
IS CRUCIA
THR INVESTIGATION, SITOTIMPL PO
ADTIF REFORMATION. THE WORDINGTN
EC NO, I DON'T SAY HIN I
TESTIMONY IS CRITICAECUTOR'S
WHG TOAS IT  GNG TTIVITIESE UNDD
ANOTHALISH
CRIMINAL IS WHAT'SE AR M THAWH N
INTO AND THAT'S WHST NEE >> AND
RIGHT, FOR VTIHIM, WHO
GAVE YOU THE
GEORGICRETARY  STO TALK ABT THO
THAT QUESTION COULD ALSOADVANCE?
>> FOR SIF HE WERE TANSWERHA
QUESTHE AMENDMENT OR SE OR OTHE
SH BLING HE WERE
TO ANSWER THATUE
YES, I TESIDENN EST WE NEEDE  F
AND THAT WOULD BE VERY
SIHE P
NEVER LEARNED ASWE DO KNOWRDED
COULE T ERY WAS RE WE JUST
WOULE RLY STAGESF THIS
IHE ON BET GRAHAP WAS RDS A CAD
RAFFENSPERGE T
STATE OF GEORGKNOW WHETHER- DON
REER THAT WAHERE ARE PEOPL
THOLLECTIONSOF WHAT GRAHAMSK
EI THE WAS ASKD VO
OF THE OR.
ANOTHER AUDI OAT, T  WE'LL FIN
NEESE  THAT CALL TELLING EM WHA.
>> ANDS THG N OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTR PR
S HOMEFLORIDA.
EALED DA DETAIOF THE INVESTIGATD
NARM IN YOUR
>> WL, THINKS
RI. THT IS HE
RESIDENT
CLTIONAL SECURITY DOCUMEHIM,UMIH
KNOWINGLY DI OS
NEEN NN
S HANDLING OF THOSNTS,IOLATES SS
KED
ANY DOCUMENT H
DIDN'T HAVE IT WHEN Y
, THAT WTRUCTI TPLS
E THATE JUST DON'T
BUT ONE THINS CLEAR IS
VERPHISID IN  FI D
E
HAPHAZAR